[Music]
first my here are some BuzzFeed lists I
saw recently that seemed a little weak
for example 16 faces of people getting
just average massages okay
do we really need that list a nasty tile
exactly yeah 19 cats that found Ukraine
on a map 19 yeah 41 middle-aged women
who look like teachers but aren't oh she
actually where I look at her she's got
to be a teenager we're moving on 22
congressmen who actually sleep with
their wives there are 22 yeah yeah and
look at this the 10 best fingers
here's the next one seven tricks to keep
your Hitman interested that's so stupid
sorry 423 photos of Barbara Walters you
don't want to see a lot of those Wow
here look at this one four things your
hamster isn't telling you he's got bad
news oh hell 19 forms of birth control
that can be found at any construction
site that's handy crowds turning on us I
know I know
just keep reading keep reading look at
this 128 giraffes commonly mistaken for
skinhead that's just unfortunate is too
bad it's not that you're absolutely not
his fault the 13 cuts of meat that most
resemble edward james olmos
[Applause]
[Applause]
seventy-nine thoughts everyone has had
while idling in the left turn lane of
Valley Drive and treat Boulevard in
Harrisburg Pennsylvania 15 face tattoos
that will help you get a raise at Popeye
if you're wondering 31 breakfast mascots
we'd like to see naked 21 totally
awesome 90s TV shows you probably missed
if you spent your childhood chained to a
washing machine in a stranger's basement
and finally 15 famous animals you won't
believe our lesbians
[Applause]